hey everybody uh welcome to Mega bit I'm
Peter Brown here with Justin hawald
who's busy Googling for images of me
yeah if you search for Peter Brown on
the internet the first in inance is not
a regular Peter Brown but it it quickly
goes not safe for work I don't recommend
it anyway uh we're here today to play
PaRappa the Rapper did you talk about
this last week or I I'm the one who
mentioned you mentioned it I guess you
know you just get flooded with requests
to play games and mine was on top
somehow yeah um so this came out when
probably 98 97 only there were something
that would tell us there was a 99 is
that what I just saw whoa 97 all right
yeah so this was a uh a really quirky
PlayStation music game that kind of um
well it sort of brought like Rhythm
games into the like the popular space I
guess you'd say like I know it was one
of my favorites one of the first ones
that I had played and and it is a really
really weird game um it's very weird but
very entertaining and from Nana Ona
right the developer at the time how do I
work a PC Justin has no idea how to use
this laptop which is awesome uh all
right so let's get into it uh so yeah
this is a music game where you play a
dog who's also a
rapper see yeah so n a second they did
Vib ribbon as well hey guys can we get
the game music back
here we got some other music playing
too all right let's just watch this
intro for a
second
yeah see this is somebody's personal
music which is going on top of it yeah
if you guys can hear this totally into
that all dressed up for us ain't that
right right what do you say how about if
uh you and I so if you guys are watching
this on the uh the
gamespot.com if you refresh the video
you'll also be able to access chat there
we're going to cycle back and forth
between the different chats that's not
true at all I refreshed for chat Jo chin
is here but it's gone now it's Joe I
have traveled the Seven Seas I have
crossed every mountain known to man and
I know that the mighty powers that I
have are enough for jerks like you I
shall put on my magic gloves of glory
and shall take you on a cruise to
destroy all of you now let me tell you
of this one incident at this coffee shop
in where there
were oh here we go again let's go bye
now
bye wow I need to become a hero
too
H but how could I possibly do
that yeah I know I got to
believe I know
welcome to the fruits fruit fruits I
trust that you are here to redeem
yourself and toire skills that are
necessary for your
goals why is it fruit but he's a big
onion I shall give you my best you're
asking the wrong question let see if you
can challenge
my all right I'm going to do my best to
hear
uh this game looks really simple and it
is but the timing sometimes is really
strict
yes and you have like no lead in to like
your turn
really nevertheless to get a lesson from
te to now kick kick punch punch CH chop
block once more now kick kick punch
get it's going to get Rocky we going to
move down to the next J now
duck jump
jum
turn carefully jump jump
puse and turn
turn yeah I see you're getting better
kick to the limit in order to get her
now kick
punch kick
punch CH
block bad you rapping
bad going to get hard and oh
no
and
and used to play he would like mash
buttons like the button like the last
note until like the measure ended he
would get really good scores but I never
figured out like if that's good or not I
mean I guess if you get a good score it
is
but the Rhythm in there is not easy to
dock
Jesus
block duck
punch
punch duck
duck duck
duck jump
kick
KCK pun
punch awful going to Awful did not make
it he doesn't again what again quick
call out to Grim 0187 this is one of the
first games that he uh bought when he
bought a PS1 nice this game also came
out on PlayStation Portable and there
was a sequel on PS2 which I've actually
never played I've never played the
sequel and there was a sequel on
Playstation called umjammer Lamy which I
don't know what an umjammer is
but that was about sort of where this
game is about rap that one was about
rock and roll I
guess get
big fan of this visual
style had a very small st
did it's on the PlayStation Network so
you can download
it yeah I see you're getting better KCK
to the limit in order to get now kick
punch kick
punch
chock so there's a change made in the
English
version sorry yeah of J lamb they took
out the part where you die and go to
hell
and jump and
P jump
my God it's so
tough you find this is difficult play
yeah and I feel like I'm even like right
on the beat too that's the part that I
don't
get
kick
kick duck duck
punch
punch duck duck
yeah come
on that's it
for good job paraa you can go on to the
next stage now Yahoo all
right going try next one
yes I have a bunch of Wikipedia Pages
the end of my simple introduction put up
your fists you evil Crusaders let me
knock you
out yeah we'll save it's going to take a
second actually go to no to say no
no we won't save hang
on so this this was back when when
Japanese games did Rhythm Rhythm pedal
so much better than we did oh
yeah and we find we did eventually catch
up by we I mean it's a great day Western
companies so what do you guys want to do
not me I'd never made game go down to
the
beach okay sounds cool we never caught
up with this craziness I guess SpongeBob
SquarePants that's pretty weird it's
pretty weird
but this is just so out of left field
eating check that out ice looking donut
superch limo
900 yeah the maximum speed is tuned up
to
43,2 and vinyl Panther seats
too vinyl Panther
seats that's got to be expensive a vinyl
Panther
hi hi how do you like my new car guys
they even had the reflection in the the
color is awesome we ever move on beyond
the play only that it's a convertible
and it is capable of Leaping tall
buildings in a single bound would you
girls like to go to the beach with me
sure only if all of us can go of course
of course come on girls sit up f with me
you guys can sit in the
back everybody hold on getting the hot
tub yeah
really
although
no telling what he is what he does with
it he's kind of creepy he's a bit of a
creep
yeah and this is also bad design why
would you have the exhaust blowing on to
anybody I have no idea what's happening
if I only had license I could take Sunny
anywhere
how can I do
that you got to
believe yeah I know I got to believe he
knows this is also a motivational and
teaching tool for children
yeah sure you want to learn how to drive
huh it's harder than you think it is if
you think you can handle it try this
R only all things in life were dictated
by rap
ability
all right we're here just sitting in the
car I want you to show me if you can get
far step on the
gas step on the gas step on the
bres stepes oops I'm not do on the
gas step on the gas when I say bo bo bo
you say bam bam bam no PA in between
come on let's JB step on the gas step on
the gas step on the brakes step on the
brakes step on the the brakes step on
the brakes step on the gas step on the
gas I'm glad you know which way to go
but it ain't going to stop me here we go
check and turn the signal to the right
check sign to the right now turn to the
right check and turn the signals to the
left check turn the signals to the left
now turn to the left now
turn they give you like no warning when
it comes to those quick on man we got an
emergency you see do you know why we St
the car do I
know time is a little
off do you know why we sto the car do I
know why we stop the car yes what what I
forgot to close the door you CL door
there you
go now just don't forget this ain't Kung
Fu come on again check and turn the
signal to the right turn to the right
step on the gas now turn to the right
check and turn the signal to the left
check turn signal to the left step on
the gas now turn to the left step on the
gas now turn to the left step on the
brakes step do you know why we stop the
car again do I know why we stop the car
you got to do it
again it's rough dude we turned this
down to easy didn't we there's I don't
think there is
the PSP version did have a the PSP
version that you said a
difficulty I mean I just all right we're
here just sitting in the car I want you
to show me if you can get step on the
gas St step on the
gas step on the brakes
step now step on the gas
step gas gas when I say bo bo bo you say
bam bam bam no pause in between come on
let's J step on the gas step on the gas
step on the brakes step on the brakes
step on the gas step on the gas I'm glad
you know which way to go but it ain't
going to stop me here we go check and
turn the signal to
the you
that turn the signals to the left turn
the signal to the left now turn to the
left now turn left turn
wo ho ho ho stop the car we got an
emergency can't you see do you know why
we stop the car do I know why we stop
the car
yes what do you know why we stop the car
do I know why we stop car yes what what
I forgot to close the door you forgot to
close the
door all right so it's it's hard to
listen to the me like I can't set it up
with the music I have it's only visual
there's something off of the Tim a
little
bit you can hear that it comes out a
little that was good that was it's
always the like the little sound clips
that um you that like you know when PR
wraps basically they can truncate
themselves so like if you're not you
right timing like between two notes
everyone after that is just up
what but I was only bad I didn't go down
to
Awful that wasn't awful give me a
license if I if I can't do it this
time I want you to show me if you can
get far step on the gas step on step on
the
gas step on the
brakes break break now step on the
gas tap
the wrong button
there gas step on step on the brakes
step on the brakes step on the brakes
step on the brakes step on the gas step
on I'm glad you know which way to go but
it ain't going to stop me here we go
check and turn the signals to the right
check turn the signals to the now turn
to the right now turn
right check and turn signal to the left
and turn the signal to the left now turn
to the left now turn
left wo ho ho ho stop the car we got an
emergency can't you see do you know why
we stop the
car we
stop do you know why we sto the car we
stop car I
know that's what I forgot to close the
door you forgot to close the door
now don't forget this ain't Kung Fu come
on again check and turn the signal to
the
right step on the gas now turn to the
right it again all right let me try let
me try hopefully this doesn't become a
Donkey Kong cart situation
where
like you want the you want to just like
syn up the
sound but it doesn't seem like that
works step on the
brakes bres now step on the
gas when
I better step on the gas step on gas
step on the bres step on The Brak step
on the brakes step on the St on the gas
stepas
gladin check and turn the signal to the
right check sign to the right now turn
to the right now
turn do it again wow well that was
faster
what this is rough
I don't remember being this bad at this
game I lovey
games step on
the now step on the
gas step on the gas when I say bo bo bo
you say
unforgiving gas gas on the brakes step
on the brakes step on the brakes step on
the brakes step on the gas step on the
gas I GL you know which way to go but it
ain't going to stop me here we go check
and turn the signal to the right check
turn the signal to the right now turn to
the right now turn
right check and turn the signal to the
left check and turn the signal to the
left now turn to the left now turn
left wo ho ho ho stop the car we got an
emergency can't you see do you know why
we stop the car do I know why we stop
the car
gu what do you know why we stop the car
do I know why we stop the
car what I forgot to close the door you
forgot to close the
door not just forgiving but also giving
you clues about what the game wants you
to
do and when you're doing well
to the right check and turn the signal
to the left check and turn the signal to
the left step on the gas now turn to the
left step on the step on the BR step on
the do you know why we sto the car again
do I know why we
stop do it
again man wow that was a big drop one
more try
yeah and then I guess to see if it has
an easy setting we're no good what time
is it right now it's only been 4
minutes the chat is very supportive of
us thanks guys oh
wait
gas step on gas when I say bo bo bo you
say bam bam bam no pause in between come
on Let's Jam step on the gas
oh step on the step on the step on the
step on the gas step on the gas I'm glad
you know which way to go but it ain't
going to stop me here we go check and
turn the
signals be fair let's say that we
weren't playing this on
Playstation there might be some amount
of
lag we experiencing no no no there's no
lag here dude this game is always really
finicky for sure seriously this this is
not St car do I know
we do you know those kind of parts are
ridiculous do I know the car
yes I forgot to close the door you
forgot to close the
door now just don't forget this ain't
Kung Fu come on again check and turn the
signal to the right check and turn the
signal to the right step on the gas now
turn to the right step on the gas now
turn to the right check and turn the
signal to the left check turn the to the
left step on the gas now turn to the
left step on the brakes step on the bres
do you know why we sto the car again do
I know why we stop the car again you got
to do it oh we're so
close I'll try it again all right all
right see the problem is that we weren't
believing you got to believe you got to
believe all right here just sitting in
the car
I step on the
gas step on gas step on the
bres so someone saying the delay is
inherent in the game because I can
guarantee you the setup we have right
now there's no technical reason why
there should be controller
L it might be the case cuz I definitely
remember this
game
gas which way to go but it ain't going
to stop me here we go check and turn the
signals to the right check turn the
signal to the right now turn to the
right now turn
right check and turn the to
the what ho ho ho stop the car we got an
emergency can't you see do you know why
we stop the car do I know why we stop
the car yes what do you know why we sto
the car do I know why we sto the car yes
what I forgot to close the door you
forgot to close the door
I believe in you I got to believe you
got to believe Ain
come to the left step on the now turn to
the left step on the brakes step on the
BR do you know we sto the car
again good job woohoo did you just like
mash your way through that somehow no no
so I I would lead into everyone just by
tapping the button and then try to get
the Rhythm all right well good
job cuz that first one
was screwing up yeah yeah yeah we did it
we believed no
saving let's go let's
go
man business see now what does the chat
say cuz they were being
dicks I believed in myself basically
everyone's on my ability to
play Rhythm
games Parappa hey Parappa where are you
going with my car shut up old man how
old is Parappa supposed to be I I don't
think I ever I got a clear notion of
that let's say 16 right cuz he just got
his license so oh yeah go he doesn't
have a license yet though or maybe oh he
did get it now right yeah now he's got
it yeah but his girlfriend is someone
who's going to be picked up by this guy
with a
panther trim interior what was that hood
ornament duck oh okay normal duck head
not like a not like a rubber duck that's
not how you drive that's how I
drive more
fries
anyone who says they don't do drugs in
Jaan lot of fun wouldn't it be nice if
we could keep driving and go someplace
Far Far
Away mean she wants to run
away got drinking
wine out of
you know it's safe to fall asleep with
the wheel and
die this is all this is all a big
PSA I learned a lot as a child heavy
load
cool
game oh no I can't believe it I fell
asleep at the wheel and then crashed
into a truck dad going to bite him I
still have 59 more monthly St to pay
what am I going to tell your mother I
hope you're ready to pay for everything
I'm in trouble now how am I going to pay
for this car how can I do
that they to start selling drugs oh wait
oh okay yeah not that's that's not going
to help you pay for a car that you just
crash so you want to sell Goods at this
flea market eh
he a new boy aren't
you the most important thing in selling
Goods here yeah it's not money it's
alone so if you want to sell Goods here
come stand next to me follow me
R Master Prince please
swall
I'm working in the flea market so early
I've been working since my mama was a
baby just because the rhym is slow that
don't mean that you can't
flow in the rain in the snow the got to
got the funky
flow in the rain in the
snow the
fun
be
yeah that's not work
now I
can
like
hopefully we just get done in one done
one I don't want to play this again in
the rain in theow in the rain got the
got the funky flow got the take Funk FL
in the rain or in the snow in the rain
or in the snow got the funky funky flun
fun
FL
you you have never sold everything
everything oh know all right let me try
let me
try all right uh before I do this we're
going to take a quick break but stay
with us we'll be right back and you can
watch me try to rap again maybe I'll
succeed this time stay
tuned we're back Justin ready yeah we
looked up some hot cheats did
sure all right I got this I promise
you
right I'm in the fle market so early
I've been working here my mama was a
baby he's been working here since his
mother was a
baby you started early in the Dr
TR
funun friendly all you ever need is to
be nice and friend all you ever need is
to be nice friendly all you ever need to
be nice and
friendly
from I can a cap like
this
like bring you Lu the skunk over
here the over here comes with the
TR you have a gas truck and a skunk is
for like dank like a dank smell
for you s like know what you're talking
about not so know I know all the drug
things in the snow in the rain in the
snow got the funky funky flow got the
funky funky flow
let me tell you something that I never
before I think you you told us last
time everything I never everything
everything you have never sold
everything everything you everything
everything Mone is all you need Mone is
all you need Mone Mone Mone is all you
need is all you need
uhuh uhuh come on let's do it all over
again do it all over
again man let's start from the the spot
where we did when we made
it
right I'm working in the flea market so
early I've been working here since my M
was a baby just because the rhythm is
slow that don't mean that you can't
flow in the rain in the snow in the rain
of in the snow got the got the funky
flow got the got the funky flow in the
rain in the snow in the rain of in the
snow got to got the funky flow got to
got the funky flow all you ever need is
to be nice and friendly all you ever
need is to be nice and friendly all you
ever need is to be nice and friendly all
you ever need to be night
and
is every
from I can a like
this
like I can a like
this be like number one roller of the
Seven Seas this skover year will bring
you luck
over
here over
with so it's it's actually impossible to
get cool the first time you play through
the song that's why we can't go above
good even when we're doing really
obviously doing really awesome oh yeah
why is it impossible you only get cool
unlocked on the second time you play
stage
select so it automatically handicap a
little
bit so when you get in the flow you're
not going to go any higher
than it's like if you watch when he like
sings his like note for the like icon on
the timeline his little picture is moved
like just past
this
fun
fun in the snow in a rain in the snow
got got the funky flow got the funk FL
you ever need is to be nice and friendly
need is to
bece all you ever need is to be nice and
friendly uh uhuh come on let's do it all
again are you
serious better when I was just spamming
button right
yeah so I remember playing this on PSP
and I thought I I thought it was just
like a crappy for
maybe need
upate that don't mean that you can't
flow in the rain or in the snow in the
rain or in the snow got to got the funky
flow got to got the funk FL in the rain
in the snow in the rain in the snow got
the funky flow
all to be nice and
friendly
allly uhuh uhuh come on let's do it
all TR one more time like the problem is
like even when it goes like with the
song at the right timing where it sounds
like audibly correct yeah it still is
like
no what could swallow I I actually don't
know well the dude works at a flea
market and he eats bugs as a lizard
right so it kind of makes
sense you guys have any Hot Tips tips
yeah Pro
tips besides
stop got to got the funky flow got got
in the rain or in the snow in the rain
in the got the got the funky flow got
the got the funky FL all you ever need
is to be nice and friendly all you ever
need is to be nice and friend all you
ever need is to be nice and friendly all
you ever need is to be nice and
friendly Max come on
out I'm totally fine with that
like this I try to sell a like this I
never dream it would be like
this
rushing say we're rushing the beat is
the same as saying
suck the over here comes with the TRU
the over here
the oh yeah trust me this is not as easy
as it looks the timing of the beat and
the rhythm is like really weird most of
the other tips focus
on doing what Parappa is doing with his
Budd
here that's
I'm right on the beat with
him listen this I have never sold
everything everything I have never sold
everything everything you have never
sold everything everything you have
never sold everything everything money
money money is all you need money money
money is all you need money money money
is all
you uh uhuh come on let's do it all over
again this one guy say stop trying to
follow the song exactly and press the
buttons to the beat you don't have to
hit every single X that appears you can
hit four of Eight in Line and still win
what me try
this
or if Max will come in and save us yeah
Max why don't you come out here and try
to save us help us Max one Kenobi I'd
like to see him try I just want to see
someone else fail yeah I'd like to see
you try come on oh you going to do this
Max yeah see what you got yeah show us
how it's done
Max it's a it's like play so x square
circle
triangle right and left are just the
bumpers
right good luck Max said I've never
played this
game baby because the
is this is actually
Shaggy
C hey man whatever all I'm saying is
your icon is like past the little button
so I'm I don't get this game
sometimes s a c like this I can sell a
bot like this I will try to sell a like
this are you following the icon or are
you listening to the music cuz it's so
but it's so after so
late
pop this feel so late yes
aot a box I know I'm on the run in the
rain or in the snow in the rain in the
snow got got the funky flow got got in
the rain or in the snow in the rain or
in the snow the funky funky flow got
funk Funk
FL this isn't
good this is not what I was
expecting I never sold everything
everything you have never sold
everything everything
oh yeah going to bad go the
bad
all all
need all
you get out of here get out of here
thanks a lot thank thank thanks
Max
okay that that's not going to help the
impression that uh that we don't suck at
this we learned a valuable lesson there
it's when the when the letter pops it's
when the letter
Pops I was going to try and just go on
the Rhythm that time as well I was going
to stop I was going to ignore the screen
ignore the
voices I have a feeling I would have
done okay we'll see if we learn from Max
if we take any lessons from this or if
we just need Max to play through the
rest of the that might be what we
okay it's Sunny's birthday tomorrow and
for the party we need someone to get a
present we need someone to buy a cake
and someone to set up uh-huh and how
should we decide well how about JN now
we look like pieces of idea ready
John Yay I won I'll be the producer oh
all right let's continue
John oops one more time which is just
paper scissors rock I won I'll get the
present and that means you have to get
the cake Parappa okay all right
everybody let's all do our jobs and get
ready for tomorrow right
on oh
man there's nothing but hate in the chat
God we're not even okay man we
suck yeah I
know are you like me waiting for this
cut scene to be over so we can play I
just want to prove myself
myself I want to I have to redeem myself
with no just really just really to
me cooking with
chicken hi y Parappa tomorrow's the big
day isn't
it
you want to see the cake that I
got oh okay oh you can't skip it all
right every single day stress comes in
every way I ain't got no time for nobody
my style is Rich dope fat and wit we'll
make a cake today that looks Rich crack
crack crack the egg into the bowl crack
crack crack egg into the bowl m i the
flower the M
iegg the B cra cra cra EG into the bow m
i flower into the bowl m i FL into the
bowl a cake Yes means you got to try I'm
doing this for years but don't ask me
why butter butter butter joins the bow
butter join the we're making us a cake
that you never seen before making us a
cake that you never seen heat up the
oven now we're on a roll heat up the
oven
now ch's the name of my
soul
she's so
pissed all right I don't even want to
look at
the how do I how do I stop you already
press the button it's already I'm
pushing it oh
no Justin turns off the laptop yet
again every single day do you i't got no
time for no my style is Rich dope fat
and Rich we'll make a cake today that
looks Rich crack crack crack the egg
into the bowl crack crack crack the egg
into the bowl m i the FL into the bowl M
IX the flow into the bowl crack crack
crack the egg into the bowl crack crack
crack the egg into the bowl M IX the
flow into the bowl m i
the baking a cake Yes means you got to
try I'm doing this for years but don't
ask me why butter butter butter Jo the
B really good at Rock Band we're making
l a cake that you've never seen before
us you never seen before heat up the
oven now we're on a roll heat up the
oven now on a
roll's the name of my
soul the name of your
soul Max is laughing away can hear you
laughing hear you laughing
Max oh he's just coming out
already all right one more try
my sty
is wi'll make a thats Rich C theegg the
bowl crack crack crack the egg into the
bowl m i the flower into the bowl M IX
the flow into the bowl crack crack crack
the egg into the bowl crack crack crack
egg into the bowl M IX the flow into the
bowl M iix FL baking a cake Yes means
you got to try I'm doing this for years
but don't ask me why H butter butter
butter joins the bow butter butter
butter joins the bow we're making lot of
cake that you've never seen before make
us the cake that you never seen before
heat up the oven now we're on a roll
heat up the oven now we on a roll chep's
the name of My
Soul Your Soul the other day I was
called a little turkey but I'm a chicken
G your beef jerky put the cake in the
oven for a while put the cake in the
oven for a while leave it there come on
CLE the
P all right Max come here show show us
how it's done come on
Max jerk you big
jerk big
jerky if you do this in one go I I quit
I'm quitting I'm going to go toess comes
in I got going to go into Starbucks and
start
working make a cake today that looks
Rich crack crack crack the egg into the
bowl crack crack crack egg into the bowl
m i the
FL m
i what's going on
Max
the to
the did you notice this one's different
you try on do this for years but don't
ask me why butter butter butter joins
the
bow butter
we're making us a cake that You' never
seen before make us a cake that you
never seen before heat up the oven now
we now we
aoll the name of my
soul the name of your soul the other
daying awful awful Max got
believe leave it there come on clean the
pile leave it there come on clean the p
one hit wonder Max no I thought I
thought yeah but I thought you thought
what yes oh we're not complete failures
you to go to Starbucks
yeah
McDonald my style
is that
looks C theegg no that's right CRA C CRA
the egg into the b m i flow into the bow
m i FL into the bow crack crack CRA
youing good now crack crack crack CRA
into the
m the
m do this for years but don't ask me why
butter butter butter joins the
bow the we making L of cake
he the now we're on a roll
heat up the now we roll's the name of my
soul the name of your soul the other day
I was a little this level is about
making
Ed in the a while the in the other for a
while leave it there come on clean the
pile leave it there come on clean the
pile I try I want to try again give to
hey wal here we go here we go oh man we
got 10 minutes left
thanks how quickly how quickly the
support bench
turns yeah Max boo
Max my style is dope fat wi we'll make a
c today that looks Rich crack crack
crack the egg into the bowl crack crack
crack egg into the bowl m i the FL into
the bowl m i the FL went the ball crack
crack crack the egg into the bowl crack
crack crack egg into the bowl MX the FL
into the bowl M IX the FL into the
bowling a cake Yes means
you you can't look at the screen at all
I I can't I have to just listen
to making us a cake that you've never
seen before we're making us a cake that
youve never seen heat up the oven now
we're on a roll heat up the oven now we
going to roll's the name of my
soul the name of yes the other day I was
called a little turke I wish he would I
wish he could turn it
off the cake in the oven for a while put
the C in the oven for a while to it
there come on clean the pie leave it
there come on clean the pie put the cake
in the oven for a while put the cake in
the oven for a while leave it there come
on clean the pile leave there come on
clean the P here I got a little sample I
just don't have a samp here cuz amle
times just what we don't have money and
times what we don't
have all right let me
see like I had it and then it changed it
up a
bit
Ah made it further that time y this one
has a lot
more got no time for no my style is but
then when he starts singing it it throws
me off looks CRA crack crack the egg the
bow crack crack crack egg into the bow m
i the FL into the bow m i the fler into
the bowl crack crack crack the egg into
the bowl M iix the flow into the bowl M
iix flow to the bow baking a cake Yes
means you got to try I'm doing this for
years but don't ask me why butter butter
butter joins
the zero points how it even possible
making us the cake that never seen
before heat up the oven now we going to
roll heat up the oven now we going to
roll cheap Che the name of my
soul the name of your soul the other day
I was called a little turkey but I'm a
chicken G your beef jury put the cake in
the oven for a while put the cake in the
oven for a while leave it there come on
clean the pile
leave next try try it I think I think we
can get this
now we got this every single day stress
comes I got no time for CR the a little
style is Rich dope fat and witch we'll
make a cake today that looks Rich we're
not going to sayra the egg into the bowl
CRA crack crack egg into the bowl M iix
the flower into the bowl M IX the flower
into the bowl crack crack the egg into
the bowl crack crack crack egg into the
bowl m i the fler into the bowl m i
the
the the we're making us a cake that
you've never seen before we're making us
a cake that you never seen heat up the
oven now we're on a roll heat up oven
now we on a roll chep chep chep's the
name of my
soul name up your soul the other day I
was calling a little turkey but I'm a
chicken G it your beef jerky put the
cake in the oven for a while put the
cake in the oven for a while leave it
there come on clean the pile leave it
there come on clean the P put the cake
in the oven for a while put the cake in
the oven for a while leave it there come
on clean the pie leave there come on
clean the pie here I got a little sample
here I don't have a sample cuz ample
times just what we don't have cuz money
and time just what we don't have a
chicken in the kitchen is making all the
sound the cake is done while we were
sitting around all we got to do is apply
the final touches all we got to do is
apply the final touches take off the
shrimp the clam and the purchase take
out the shrimp the clam and the
purchese I thought I
had we just a lesson
four
had that
one you were
close every single day stress comes in
everyway I ain't got no time for no body
my style is Rich dope fat and wi we'll
make a cake today that looks Rich C
crack crack the egg into the bowl crack
crack crack egg into the bowl M IX the
flour into the bowl M iix the flow into
the bowl crack crack crack the egg into
the bowl crack crack crack egg into the
bowl M IX the flower to the Bowl M iix
flower to the Bowl C Yes means you got
to try I'm doing this for years but
don't ask me why butter butter butter
joins the bowl butter butter butter
joins the bowl we're making L of cake
that you never seen before making us a
cake that you never seen before heat up
the oven now we're on a roll heat up the
oven now we on a roll Che CH ch's the
name of my
soul name of your soul the other day was
called a little turkey but I'm a chicken
G your beef jerky put the cake in the
oven for a while put the cake in the
oven for a leave it there come on clean
the pile leave it there come on C the
P try try one more time and then Max you
can get in one more if you want I think
we're going to have to wrap it up but
let's make a cake
man
it all right what are you saying chat
every single day stress comes I got no
time for no style is Rich do fat and
witch we'll make a cake today that looks
Rich crack crack crack the egg into the
bowl crack crack crack the egg into the
bowl M iix the flour into the bowl M iix
the flow into the bowl crack crack crack
the egg into the bowl crack crack crack
the egg into the bowl M IX the flow into
the bowl M IX FL into the
bow you I'm doing this for years the
audio sounds right
the never seen before making us a cake
that you never seen before heat up the
oven now we on a rollat up the oven now
we on a
roll the name of my soul the name
of all right I give up Max up to you oh
Jesus it's when you get into the groove
and then like you start listening to
Parappa and you're like oh no now it's
on but like what kind of really game is
this where if you sound right but it's
wrong but if you sound wrong you get it
every single day stress comes in every
way I got no time
for we'll make a cake today that looks
Rich crack crack crack the egg to the
Bowl crack crack crack egg into the bowl
M IX the flower into the bowl M IX the
flower into the bowl crack crack CRA
into the bowl crack crack crack neck
into the bowl m i flow into the bowl f i
FL into the bowl making a cake Yes means
you got to try I'm doing this for years
but don't ask me why butter butter
butter joins the bow butter butter
butter join Bowl making us a cake that
you've never seen before make us a cake
that you never seen before heat up the
oven now we're on a roll heat up the
oven now we on a roll ch ch chep's the
name of my
soul name of your soul the other day I
was called a little turkey but I'm a
chicken G your beef jerky put the cake
in the oven for a while put the cake in
the oven for a while leave it there come
on clean the pile leave it there come on
clean the pile P the cake in the oven
for a while put the cake in the oven for
a while leave it there come on clean the
pile leave it there come on clean the
pile all right gdr next
time pretty wonky right that one's weird
I no no excuses no
excuses uh I guess we didn't believe
didn't believe I thought I believed in
myself I believed in you and you I
believed in
Max uh yeah thanks for watching everyone
that was Parappa theppa an old
PlayStation classic um and this was meab
bit and you should try this out yourself
just to prove how much better you are
than us because bet you can do it much
better um come back at 2 pm today for
multiple players with Chris Waters and a
bunch of friends and otherwise thanks
for joining me guys thanks see you next
week on meab bit Mondays at 11:00 a.m.
take
care